here but we're not going to have time to
answer all of them uh there is a link
that maybe you could share on the chat
as well for anybody who wants to learn
more and you can also go to our
symposium page we have links to all the
participants or sorry all the speakers
uh all of the links you can find there
okay so monika over to you thank you
very much dr vasudevan great to hear
about all this yeah thank you so much
thank you all for your patience
thank you so much dr sona vasudevan
now i would like to welcome dr philip
camp q he will be talking on
undergraduate and high school
computational biology education at
carnegie mellon university
dr philip is an associate teaching
professor and assistant department head
in the computational biology department
at carnegie mellon university he is a
passionate educator who has taught a
range of stem courses to a diverse
collection of student groups an
experienced administrator who works to
make the student the central focus of
our educational programs and a leader of
several successful projects open online
education over to you dr phillip
okay thank you so much for the kind
introduction i'm going to share my
screen
and you can find information about our
department at
cbd.cmu.edu so we have a nice short url
and that's going to have information
about the the programs that i'm talking
about today as well as
all of our educational programs so we're
in in pittsburgh pennsylvania in in the
us
um we have a phd program that's joint
with university of pittsburgh which is
actually just down the street from our
university it's kind of rare to have two
universities that actually are
directly adjacent to each other we also
have two masters programs one in
computational biology and another in
automated science so we have opened
a laboratory that is totally robotically
driven where students can learn about
how to not just program the robot to
perform experiments in biology but also
to train the robot to make decisions
about what future experiments to run
based off of the results of experiments
so you have this closed-loop
experimentation system
but what i was going to talk about today
is is two projects that i have
essentially
created um one and serve as a director
of
one is our undergraduate degree in
computational biology and another is a
high school program that i founded with
josh kangas
that educates students over the summer
within the field of computational
biology and that program makes us
somewhat unique so i i i'm very proud of
both of these programs i know that
others you know may talk about more
graduate education but i wanted to share
the type of thing that we do with with
both undergraduate and high school
students um if you're interested in our
other programs i would encourage you to
go to our website and check them out
because we have wonderful programs
for every variety of of interest
so
um in our undergraduate program
we accept students directly to
colleges
within carnegie mellon so at most
american universities you just apply to
the university
and then when you arrive you decide on
what your major is going to be and
everybody can decide on whatever major
and then that means that in many places
computer science has like
you know thousands of people um at a
time and and so it makes it very
difficult to have any sort of personal
relationships or this type of thing
because you have just huge classrooms
and you're just getting students through
we're a little bit different in that
students apply to schools based off of
their interests and so our department is
one of seven departments within the
school of computer science the others
are things like human computer
interaction machine learning and so on
and we have a very very selective school
so
it's one of the most selective
institutions in the u.s
the acceptance rate is only
unfortunately about five percent that
means that we don't get to see as many
talented students as we probably could
we're one of four majors that students
can choose from once they're accepted
the others being computer science
artificial
intelligence and human computer
interaction
and all the four of those major students
are trained very very computationally
first so there may there are plenty of
bioinformatics
um majors out there already most of them
are aimed towards biologists and i think
what differentiates us is that we are
training computational scientists first
and foremost you know we keep hearing
about the computational and big data
revolution in biology and so um
certainly our students receive a great
deal of biological training we have an
entire core of study that's devoted to
biological foundational coursework but
we feel that that it's just as important
to train them as computational
scientists alongside some of the
smartest undergraduate minds in computer
science in the world
and then we have an entire core
computational biology coursework that
sits at the intersection of all this
math and computer science and biology
and physics and cabinet students take
and what's nice about this is that
those core cs math requirements are the
same the computer science majors get so
we know that our students are being put
through a very very rigorous
kind of world famous training process at
the undergraduate level
one of the cool things that this means
that we can do
is our students come in and they take
a mathematics course that's usually even
by math majors only taken as juniors or
seniors where they prove theorems and
learn about discrete mathematics our
students do that in their first semester
we know they come in as very very
talented programmers or if they're not
they become very talented programmers
quickly
um
and so in our second semester we teach
students an entire course devoted to
what we call great ideas in compio so
that's our first
cohort that we had
and it's if you search for that i should
be easy to find i've got an entire
website about the course it contains
slides and descriptions of some of our
student projects that they did as well
as kind of the philosophy of the course
and how we've set it up
um we have a collection of course aims
the the i like talking about this course
just a little bit because i uh founded
it with carl kingsford and i've taught
it for three years
where the central aim is to show
students what has made biology a
computational discipline it's um
inherently a data-driven computational
discipline in 2021
and so we tell the story so to speak of
what has happened to make that the case
so um throughout this we find that you
know there you know there's these sub
aims of for example you have fundamental
algorithmic topics like dynamic
programming that comes up several times
throughout the course
we take this big broad view of
computational biology to find really
cool ideas outside of standard topics
i'll mention that briefly here in a
second
we profile topics that have actually
been so important that they've gone off
and and informed things that are outside
of biology and computer science
things like how blast works really you
know for for database search or things
like neural networks
we also point students towards primary
research that any moment of the course
i'm always show students the actual
research papers that this came from
whether it comes from 1970 or whether it
comes from just a few years ago
our students do group projects and we
also plug in world leading researchers
to to give guest lectures to our
students as well so they can see that
this is very much a living and breathing
discipline
um when when we teach these first-year
students the first half of the course is
devoted to these classic topics in
genomics things like the brown graphs
for genome assembly things like
global and local sequence alignment
smith waterman algorithm read mappings
we explained how the burrows wheeler
transform works and and how that's
applied to read mapping you know again
this is the sort of thing that you would
typically see in maybe a phd level class
or maybe a final semester undergrad
course but we're able to teach it to
first-year
undergraduates
and then in the second half of the
course we take this big uh broader view
of what computational biology is and we
cover things that within systems biology
we talk about the foundations of neural
networks as well as you know explore how
this has affected uh this really neat
algorithm called the elon kashtan
algorithm and systems biology we also
talk about algorithms in nature we talk
about spatial and evolutionary game
theory turing patterns things that you
might not typically see in a one year or
one semester
overview course
pretty much because they're beautiful
ideas that have led to a lot of other
cool work um even if they aren't you
know at the at the forefront of what is
going on in computational biology today
one of the other cool things about our
undergrad degree is that we guarantee at
least one semester of research to all of
our majors that goes back to our point
about going to university and finding
yourself one of a thousand other majors
in a certain subject and it being a
battle to be able to have any sort of
research experience we only have
about 20 majors per year and so that
means that we compare our faculty with
all students who want to do research and
we do this because
it's what our students told us they
wanted so when we met with prospective
students the kids kept saying over and
over again you know i really want to
come here so i can do research what can
you do and so we work with our faculty
to guarantee that
um
we also connect our students downstream
to opportunities outside of
um you know their degree we know that
our degree is very expensive to the
point that was just race and we want to
do everything that we can to help
students of all
in all of our programs get connected to
opportunities in industry
often hearing from what our alums are
doing so this is at one of our events
and we hold these virtually as well we
send resume books of students
to to alums and contacts in industry and
so on and we also try to have fun with
our students too so um even when it's
cold in pittsburgh in the winter time we
find something to do with them uh going
snow tubing
so um that's a kind of a
big picture about what we do with our
undergrad degree
and our undergraduate degree has only
recently graduated its first
students who have had transferred in
from other majors
our first main cohort
because we we've started four years ago
our first main cohort is going to be
graduating this spring so
it'll be exciting to see all the sorts
of things that they head off to do
although we know they're they're
interested in
medical careers whether or not that
means within medical school or not
or going off to industry whether that's
biotech pharma or a traditional tech
firm
so that's one of the programs that i
wanted to discuss and the other is our
high school program in computational
biology that's one of a suite of
programs that
is offered by carnegie mellon so i think
there are 11 high school programs that
we have over the summer
that are all taught by professors
and that allows students to come to
campus under normal circumstances and
have kind of a student experience on
campus for our program runs for three
weeks
some of the programs run for six weeks
where students are in the classroom
full-time throughout the day or doing
working on something um you know for
eight hours a day for every weekday
and so we have this very intensive
you know full-time program for a short
period of time with with rising seniors
in high school so 16 17 year old
students um
we told students you know when we
started
just as we communicate our our goals for
my first year undergrad course we
communicate our goals very very upfront
for our high school program too um so we
tell students the first and foremost
thing that we want to do is have fun
what's wonderful about this and i'll tie
this to point number five is that we um
we don't assign grades there's no
metric
of success in our program other than
just learning there's not no
deliverables students complete a short
project but in terms of the core content
that they're learning the goal of the
program is solely to learn and to have
fun doing so
so that means we can really challenge
students too because there are no stakes
we don't have students climbing climbing
over each other to try and get a higher
grade so they can move on and get into
the next school it's not something that
we have to to worry about frankly
um
as part of this students usually will
learn a new programming language so we
currently use go we may change that in
the future but we use a language that's
kind of outside of what students
typically do so that students don't come
in and say well i already know how to
program in python because this way
students will learn something new
regardless
we want them to appreciate that
computation is everywhere in biology
that biology is a very much a
computational discipline in 2021 and we
want students to write their own code so
kind of the full cycle of how our
program works is that we present
students with some biological program
problem
we explain to them how we're going to
solve it computationally we then show
how you might do this by breaking it up
into smaller pieces but the students
solve all of those pieces and then put
them back together into a very large
piece of code that they can then apply
to some real biological data set those
real biological data sets are taken from
either
the microbiome of the three rivers in
pittsburgh so we have two rivers that
flow together into a third and the two
rivers are very different from each
other they flow through different sorts
of environments one goes by a lot of
steel mills the other is much more rural
and so we captured on a boat we went out
and got
water samples with our students from
different seasons and we got a lot of
data sets um metagenomics data sets
but we also used the opportunity of the
pandemic to uh look at publicly
available genome data sets for
for sars cove too as well so but our
main topic of focus is in microbiology
and we communicate to students how our
classroom works so just as we
communicate up front our goals we tell
students why we've set up the program in
the way that we have so we talk to them
about active learning and about how if
we can get our students to do as much in
the classroom as possible as opposed to
just listening to me drone on
and receiving information that
regardless of their background
they will see a marked increase
in
what their
outcome is so in their ability
and that often this doesn't feel like
the experience of learning and other
studies have shown that even though
students are objectively learning more
via active learning
they feel like they're learning less and
we tell students that that that feeling
of
uh
internal struggle is what learning feels
like
we
use this sort of research educational
research to inform a transition to our
online classroom so
over the past two years we've had to run
this program remotely to students across
the country
and
we use best practices for this one of
the things that we do partly based off
of student input is
we now have students solve problems in
teams of four or five so at most points
of the program students are working
together to solve some coding challenge
and they're in small groups doing this
and they can code all in one window
that's shared through something called
atom
so they can all see the same coding
window and then they can all run the
code together
so this creates this really nice kind of
group
dynamic where students have input from
teaching assistants and input from us
the instructors as we're roaming around
but they're all working together
constantly
so that even though they're online
they're able to really uh do something
all the time in the program so what is
it that we cover
um
remember i mentioned our three rivers we
ask you know how is it that the bacteria
that are present in these rivers change
over time how are they different from
one river to the other
um how is seasonality important to this
and we use this to to come up with
simple metrics that are the metrics that
are used by biologists but very easy to
explain metrics for quantifying the
diversity of a single bacterial sample
or comparing two bacterial samples and
sprinkle a little machine learning magic
on this to produce
a plot like this one that shows that
seasonality is more important than
location for determining bacterial
diversity in the three rivers
in the second module of the course and
so i've put all the lines of code that
students write or that we have as our
official solutions
um and it shows i think it's to show how
much code that students will write
because typically
when students are solving some coding
challenge we don't
continue until all the groups are
finished we were worried about whether
or not that would be possible given that
many of our students have never
programmed until like two months before
our program when we send them some
preparatory materials but then all of
our groups pretty much solve every
single one of our problems so when we
say total number of lines of code this
is
you know students are writing this much
code and using it to solve biological
examples the next of this module is
about comparing genes whether it's a
database search
and we talk about blast we don't code
the entire blast algorithm but we
discuss how it works but what we do
code are things like smith waterman
sequence alignment and the students all
code it themselves and then they apply
it to something like comparing stars
cove to source code two um so they can
actually see
something that we hear about in the news
which for example which is that the
variation of sars cove is you know
isolated to you know different points
you have a variable variation throughout
the genome so they can see that based
off of the code that they produced we
even write a genome assembler with our
students
which is our largest coding project it's
they're coding as fast as they can go
and we apply it to both simulated and
real data to show that on our simulated
data that has you know some error rate
um our assembler this is a mummer plot
on the left our assembler does really
good job at assembling the source code
to genome it does an okay job on real
data when we cut it loose on real data
and we use this as an opportunity to
show that there's pretty much always
improvements that we can make even after
we write 400 lines of code if we really
wanted a real genome assembler that
would truly work on a viral data set it
might need to be 10 times as long as
that and if we were going to apply it to
bacteria it might need to be a hundred
times as long
but once we can assemble the genome we
can find the genes in it so we have a
short module for students to find genes
and we use this to build a simple
annotation of something like a viral
genome as well as to compare
our gene finder against annotation for a
longer
larger organism and students even with a
simple approach are able to reconstruct
like 80 of the genes um in say a
sequenced uh annotated bacterium
and then in the final module of our
class we produce evolutionary trees and
we apply this to a variety of different
contexts so we look at for example
coronavirus
genomes taken from patients in different
countries to understand the initial
spread of the chronovirus around the
world we also
have students implement a simple version
of cluster
so that this is the actual um alignment
that that came from students code
so that they can start looking through
this you know throughout the course of
the pandemic
and identifying not just identifying the
variance but defining the variance
themselves and then we compare the
student definition against say the cdc's
definition what is it that makes an
alpha variant what is it that makes a
delta variant and then we can allow
students to classify each of our genomes
in some database say the uk patient
genome database to classify each patient
genome
according to which variant it applies to
and this is we just do you know normal
alpha and delta but even with this
simple classifier that we build we can
see the percentages of the alpha variant
go up you know very highly in in early
2021 and then it's completely replaced
with the delta variant so students again
have this feeling that they're really
doing the research themselves there's
nothing that the real biological
researchers did that they couldn't have
done themselves now that they have this
knowledge um finally i i point out you
know we have very very strong teaching
evaluations for our
for our program but there have been some
qualitative feedback that i love to
profile here because it reinforces our
original goals
most students when they learn to program
they learn about it in the context of
math when they think about computer
science they're thinking about google or
facebook or amazon and it's unfortunate
that even though this computational
revolution has happened our students
even very very strong students many of
whom come from very privileged
high school backgrounds have no idea
that programming can be used to solve
very important problems in biology
um
and that you know many of these problems
are very new for example with respect to
the pandemic
they love the collaboration that we have
um
they really appreciate the challenge
uh one student has called called it
grueling this year but then said
something very positive so if we're able
to balance extreme challenge
without frustrating or stressing out our
students then we really know that we're
doing our job and then i always give my
favorite quote is from nia
um who was interviewed by a blog
to discuss her her experience not just
in our program but with the pre-college
program at cmu as a whole
um and it was wonderful to see that
something that we don't tell our
students is that we pair them up based
off of their backgrounds based off of
their geography
making sure that all of our our groups
are are
kind of ethnically and gender diverse
and
uh she
we didn't tell our students this but she
recognized hey i know that they created
our groups to be as diverse as possible
often with different backgrounds strong
biologists or strong computational
students
and that that's what made the teams work
so well um so she was a wonderful
student i should say but um i always try
to end with with her quote i'm happy to
answer any questions i don't know where
we are on time but thank you for
listening
thank you very much for this
presentation we are just very short on
time in fact one minute over time but it
was great to hear about this program we
do have just uh maybe a couple of
questions that we can fit in
uh the first one is do you accept high
school students from different states uh
for example the state of louisiana
and if yes do you have a summer program
that is online or face-to-face and if
you have a link for that
yeah so we we accept students from
around the world when we're in person um
and we're hoping to be in person
next summer so you can find if you go to
our
um
go to our department website or
there's a pre-college carnegie melon if
you just google pre-college carnegie
mellon you'll find all of the programs
so it may be that you're interested you
find yourself interested in something
else and those are easy to find
all right thank you very much and it was
great to hear the presentation we're
hoping to learn more from the links that
you provided thank you